holy this road grab some strong capsular
Jack Rowland apologies and get some
meeting held on the 23rd or sep tember
don't take back a century record three
any declarations of interest your
questions on notice motion colleges all
right some of those state 2007 Thank You
German I'm good evening this report is
provides an up-to-date position on the
recommendations made by in video the
council's external auditors in their
report to this committee laughter just
one doing the I broad huh that's 17.3
statement the update November update
them in 2015 and this will be fully
implemented by descent but I believe
that is correct yes that is great i have
a firm that does actually that's been
having taken and this is I'm elevating
to a grant income registered that's
actually all known plays with all the
external
we imported grunting come in turn so the
the actual thought of the fun being the
conditions associated to the funding and
the article codes to it is attributed to
and the reporting requirements
attributed to all fun things now they're
called as well that were ensuring that
we are on top of reporting deadlines as
well in game number and that comes up
several times actually weather says a
bit about December but they will feel
all being implemented we are the only
area to mount the distal work in
progress or baby actual movement towards
a earlier production of the financial
account it we've discussed actually
having a working group in place to
actually have a look at the steps that
needed to be put into place in order to
enable us to close early meeting is
still is due to take place think in the
next week etc and some of the outcomes
we reported bash I think anything to
note is setting speaking to a number of
other authorities about that position
many of them a try myself and the same
position you're doing that would same
exercise that worker posing to do here
well many of that
I've been nation it is proposed that
Mickey resolve for the updates to the
monitoring sheet for the video
recommendations arising from file
reports the audit committee called it
for the year indian food fest march 2015
b- all agree german this report provides
members with the outcome of our own
self-assessment relating to compliance
with the public sector eternally
standards as a result of a challenge
structure we are less compliant in the
prior years or where we believe our work
is still carry down to the expected
standards the main body of the report
identifies areas for improvement
appendix 1 summarizes the outcome of the
self-assessment against the detailed
questionnaire from cetera and appendix 2
is proposed revision to the audit
charter to reflect the changes that
occur 2015 16 shall we go throw your age
yes oh okay however council something
upstairs this with myself very few
councils have actually completed the
full process in getting an external
assessment it's pretty fair to say most
they can hanging on as long as they can
Mina then the Pops can be quite
primitive on these society myself
what an external assistance that forms
part of that's one of the areas where
we're not complying I also don't
understand but will be this is a
self-assessment I mean any feedback
about how other councils affairs with
this self-assessment I mean the only
council not to comply a new person or
most about early council suffering I
think everybody has a degree of
non-compliance and mirrors houses a more
significant this year because of the
structure yeah I'm can't see group are
not be wrong perhaps as a good confirm
or you know but I don't recall having
all these reports I'll straight to us
like this in the past although it just
seems to be so many open or not but once
I can't remember ever coming to a
meeting where article you know form your
pages 50 pages of other poems to go
through here one is this year is a
purely a one-off I mean nice is this
this this particular port was to the
Audit Committee in September to 14 and
there was a similar size yeah we got one
two three four five reports now of
similar size I can't ever remember that
we had that many we might have one I had
to but something we seem to have five is
there any reason for this is it just
timing or pretty much in line with leave
the work plan that was agreed in March I
think we've had and David we have had
learned the 11 within so hm my report is
light because it was used to come to
september's meeting and had to be
deferred because we're still work to be
done so that's one reason why you have
an extra one this seems poorly on so
much of it remember facing this posh
people do you want to go through it page
by page or are you happy with some
involved is this very area submission
should be highlighting to astonish you
notes that yes thanks Barry that I think
posting this because your attention is
on page eight point three and it's item
type in code which sort of outlines in a
few bullet points the key areas where we
were you fail to meet the standard
wanted without me to be able to to your
attention and 4.1 thats related to the
change in the management structure and
had that we no longer have a senior
qualified officer the other relating to
where within the structure audit resides
and the third being around the formal
audit culture and ethics and the
external view is not yet been completed
generally what would happen with this
assessment is that the section 151
officer would actually review these the
non-compliant arias and make a decision
as to whether or not i felt i was
comfortably assured or had any concerns
redefined in the first area gives me
cause for concern not in isolation
because in instances where there is no
senior qualified office
that can still be deemed acceptable if
you have sufficient resources within the
team itself to have segregation of
duties and my own review assessment
indicates that is in the case that the
team is to lean to enable us to both
have segregation of duties and an
appropriate quality assurance so those
two combined give me cause concern and
that we need to do an urgent review of
the internal audit function what we're
recommending and here purely for
expediency is then we do it very quickly
review and I'm the person that I pull
but for some resources for the other
County to do a peer review for us of our
internal audit function and want to look
at the internal audit plan for next year
and the areas that we should be focusing
on also to actually have a look at how
we could get the right level of quality
assurance and also to actually think a
little bit about the number of all the
days and name is being covered and come
up with some recommendations for us
thank you thank you very much show me I
suppose the question is going to be as
is urgent and it's quite serious at this
point what options do we have to improve
the matter Srinu Jim well I believe d
Denis except that hopefully we're going
to get somebody down from for healthy
yes if it was because we believed it
we've spoken about this over the lowest
to afford it meetings that we feel that
they are completely understaffed oh I
understand the point but you say get
someone down from County what does that
really mean does that mean I we we have
to create a new position of points on or
do we or do we do we have options to
this
thing else this is what the review will
tell us in terms of what the options
available if I sort of just give a quick
outline of some of the areas of which I
feel that would give me a bit of course
concern and need not being assured that
we have specific enhance skills one of
the area's septum and I have spoken out
is cyber fraud for example that's not on
our audit plan that would indication
require specialist function so what we
want to understand is what are others
doing about this is to snare that we
should be looking at how do we get that
special issue is also cetera how to
bring quality of sure what are the areas
that we don't know that we've only seen
sort of thing I'm hoping to get a very
quick short shop overview and a report
on that and then make decision in terms
of do with anything is the magician
resources is a specialist resources we
need and then sort of how do we get the
relevant support I think if I can just
say how it was explained to us because
we had a pre-meeting and we've covered
this is that at this stage we have a
peer review and we take advantage of
Essex County Council to do that peer
review because Denise is in the position
to allow that to happen and then we will
know then that will be cost-free we will
then know what it is we need to put our
efforts into and where our difficulties
will be so then we will have to have
another plan but at least it will give
us an idea and that is the best way to
get an idea quickly I think that series
like this is good and equivalent of what
we need to do and then we can then agree
on
yeah original my first reaction are
written off resulting from the
restructuring but then i'm going to read
it again I hope no it's not in then I've
heard you this evening I'm convinced
it's bajar 70 subject I Scott has
addressed many offers out there yes
pedestrian ezell's turn only as we work
message county council's sorry boring
from this narrow really just about at
the moment what we're limited by our own
expertise unlimited by my knowledge and
lodgings on 5 reviews actually i think i
need to have we need to be looking at
cyber fraud we need to look at these
areas but actually what i want to have
is a specialist in this area telling us
at the areas that we need to we should
be focusing on a research to look at and
emily how do we get our quality
assurance or the appropriate level for
it adjourn at the moment and ratings
marginal victim of deposit insurance
work as well i'm reviewing that the
outlook for me audits and actually we
need to have something inside that gives
the wrong structure going forward or
provide service going forward you know
that's built into the structure that
I've thought maybe
and it also could be a range of options
the how that is dling that it could be a
take you know a replacement of that role
but there could be other options but my
concern isn't just replacing that were
all important it wouldn't address some
of the specialist issues that I've just
discussed were quite often do you need
to actually bring in specialists IT
auditors to be able to outline what
processes you need to have in place to
prevent things like say silent for my
comeback on this journey you mentioned
cyber for a bit or Qi very involved but
it's not the whole story is known as
other acts I just gave using that effect
on ya know and that in fact can be
effectively people brought in on a
temporary basis to use two-step set
something up but what will actually look
and not if I understand you correctly it
is the Reed assures don't it's sure
they'll not be long term that an oddity
falling away within one with 12 other
developer but it you we need to either
have money to do that level of quality
assurance or we need to have great
resources to be in a position to have
sufficient segregation of duties in the
officers performing your debts I think
those those the case but we also want to
have appropriate development of the team
as well appropriate supervision as well
from other experts in the field
understand where where we where best
practices and how things change in etc
so it's a it's really about ensuring
that we have a a audit function that
gives the resilience that we need and
the ouch for the actual structure the
movies going forward may I think you're
also saying
or so we didn't we do is something wrong
is that being addressed but we need to
be clear on where and how and that's
what we're hoping is key renewable will
cover at what which is the best approach
in tabler next can I ask what time scale
is on this up because we highlighted
this issue what we thought was where we
were going to be exposed several months
ago at least six months only six months
ago and we seem took made no progress in
six months old what is the timescale for
rectifying the situation as you've
outlined now I mean we talk another six
months or hoping is not known as we're
hopeful it's not we want to have a peer
review done as quickly as possible we
wanted to bring that recommendation to
yourselves we want to put something
place to have a peer review the report
without needs to come back to this
committee we don't want to hide you both
committed to what we're proposing is
that we're able to actually share that
with the chair in the vast chen if we
were able to delegate authority than to
act based on the recommendation in that
report and then to be able to take that
forward sorry the indicator so i'm sorry
i'm in a fancy thank you sure i'm not a
lot having lot turn visas that we need i
support that but as a counselor are we
happy with what would be an outsider
looking
internal a little bit I you come back so
I don't think they've got an option I
feel you're blowing pedicure but i think
we have got an option I'll do a question
she and I yeah we have fun a particular
role assistant director in the role of
transformational services and I would
hope that that particular position is
going to be directly involved in this
particularly is that they're valid IT
cyber issues on under I don't think you
I don't think we as a committee can
develop it is what we are looking at and
concerned about from the way the
organization has been set up to to do a
translation I'm sure it's not fully
understand acuesta but we have only held
me I was specifically tuned later we
have a role for a particular Angelo
break he was appointed specifically for
transformational services and he has
responsibilities range RIT and various
things you mentioned that we don't have
assurance quality shots across a number
of facets but in particular across fiber
problem and I would have thought that
you know how IT that the assistant
director responsible responsible for IT
and transformation we need to have a big
part to play in the results of the peer
review and the recommendations going
forward because that's how the alist 'ok
organization works it's it will from an
operational perspective so the a deal
with responsibility for that area will
take responsibility for the
operationally the internal audit needs
to be in a person
to be able to independently audit that
function and at the moment we need to
have the skills to build don't you
disagree with that at all I just feel
that there might be some expertise
coming from that specialist area that we
all detailed in terms of what capital
for instance of how a major contractor
you know might be able to tell us about
how they relate to these sort of quality
assurance issues for other councils so
it's all very well saying we'll get out
and I'm quite happy with Essex County
Council actually you totally have
opportunity to look another how the
directions at the same time that would
be something that we would we would be
approaching when the actual came to do
the audit and perform the audit and to
outline that this is about actually
being clear on what what is the plan or
dare you should think should we be
looking at it in or dead should we have
that hour or less not frequency should
be locally so it's sort of taken it from
a a process level rather than an
operational level when we actually come
to do an audit of any sort it will
generally go to the area themselves and
specify the terms of reference for that
audit and they will be heavily involved
in that in determining that
in part of that process on I'm thinking
German more strategically because this
is a sweetie a new prosperity team and
tactical review its tactical because
it's like and we're at risk and
strategic because it has to actually fit
with the basis of our transformation
that's all I'm trying to say is that we
shouldn't just keep this within two
narrow narrow channel I think we need I
think any would like to see a widened
early we can yourself I think the peer
review should be undertaken by the the
PM management but i think that the
results of that they've been shared and
wider input obtained into the
recommendations that black available
that's fine yeah sorry I didn't get to
that quickly enough I was clearly
feeling one way through it I do have
another question Sheriff I'm ie yeah go
back to that it was made us very cross
with you and I boss is the fact that we
have brought this up time and time again
and nobody's really taking any notice of
us you come along and you you've now
spotted what the problem is and
hopefully now they will take the
Atlantic live I mean we've we've raised
it we've raised it with the leadership
team and their they endorsed this
approach you know subject to audit
committee proving that and then we wait
the findings but they are equally as
concerned but sigh so they recognize
this has been an issue and in terms of
you know the fact that actually because
it's been flagged making a slightly
different way to what it has been
you know in the past in terms of why
it's absolutely critical to have this
appropriately resourced and willing to
explore the options that come as a
result of them yes I think I do there's
a bullet point that comes out of Johnson
and it concerns me a lot bearing in mind
what we are now embarking upon there is
no formal audience of the culture and
ethics of the council I think that's an
something I'd like to hear about how
that might be tackled I don't see it
quite as high on the priority as the
previous item means US doesn't but
nonetheless it is important because
we've embarked on an investment board
which M is going to be him to be
predicated and pivoted from the culture
and ethics of the council and I think
that's something that needs to be looked
at next quite quickly because otherwise
that that board will be off and running
quite quite certainly and doing things
and there should be a framework around
that that or what it should be a short
the council upon not but I think in we
would think it is appropriate to have
that sort of friendly precisely we've
got to cover every risk whether we think
it's not very important or not yeah but
I you know as as an audit committee we
had to cover every risk first that could
happen you know I know it's extending
this point but can we have some sort of
timeline on on this because what
concerned me we talked about you know
what with billions three months six
months while Ms Lawson will hopefully
unbelievable yeah hopefully I mean means
that's it at least a year after this was
initially flag down as a big concern and
effectively we could be a year down the
road if we don't have a set timeline
this has got to be done by so-and-so if
it just drifts again it's going to be 12
months or 15
name something in code on the
repercussions would be a Rangers for the
council determine that that little
cast-iron I'm we can come back to the
Committee on that once denieth has
spoken to her colleagues to get an idea
when the peer group in tech we are
asking for it to be done urgently so
once we get an idea of that we can come
back to our heart of empathy happy if
Denise comes back to Leslie and I before
the next audit committee yes when I mean
they could be the day before the next
review committee well if it is then it
would have to come in front of you can I
hope I understand and we certainly have
the concerns that the Demonia said we
all got it yesterday but here we are
still going down a road negotiate me or
talking about it what do you think a
reasonable period if we're comfortable
than I expected actually a call back
from resources in a county to perform
this work I can contact them this we can
come back to their committee and form
and give you the outline of the day 21
different be complete
happy with that not complete episode
although I have no doubt youtube as
gemini Bochy on the committee I have
sufficient concern and personal concern
as a member always listen to want to low
as soon as you know what is being
proposed and I think we all would have
the opportunities for their hand up if
we're not happy with it p big baby so so
we could send an email out and if
they're get people to tell i thought you
already talking about the times girl no
she's all that the result of the with
you are you know don't know about the
result but talking about if you're a
contractor who this week at a time scale
so i can go back and just confirms
colleagues when this can be undertaken
and honestly trying to get that to be
done as expediently as possible come
back to you to confirm the time scale
they can commit to and then also what
we've been discussing my own aspirations
of this can be or completed but in the
next month or two or so we now of
christmas christmas so would you prepare
your subcommittee or we can add others
to come back it's all the next door to
that job I'm just asking when
communication takes place to use it it's
a sharing email okay donors any comment
share every member is very significant
sums up there should be no admission
okay yes rotten I think it would be good
to express our deep concern about this
well we have to do that well again yeah
their position and you don't get
something hearing people anything fun
about emotions were either more than
those answers we have to
ok and so becomes everything there
right the recommendation it is promote
proposed that the committee resolves
that the outcome of the 2015 review of
the public safety internal audit
standards be agreed oh you're on a
finite you'd say they don't comply and
that the renewal of the audit charter as
amended the 2015-16 rare breed don't
know what does happen if we don't agree
maybe we can recognize a veterinarian in
the service precisely sorry just
confirming that after the recommendation
submitting those round into the green
yes I think that has two into two
remaining to add but express our concern
yeah so you know it's on record goes to
be noted well I know you know I think
we've covered it as far as we possibly
can and we've really got to wait and see
what happens ok Chum a kid we should
just threw you into something that and I
should be made that you fully endorse us
taking up every sorry I thought that
your theory endorse and for us to carry
out the peer review and that we will
come back to you with the results as a
as a committee by email and then
obviously if there's anything that you
are not happy with
then I possibility of a further
committee to be called before the march
committee yeah I think that should be
I'm not sure what that should be a
record noted by 30 day yeah yeah you're
happy with that chairman yeah yeah James
the pain yeah it's okay this site is to
advise members of progress at the end of
all this pain and to seek the approval
of a revision to reflect the available
resources
other days again I mean surely is hangs
on what we've just discussed we're being
given a choice of basic research how he
changes because he doesn't feel that we
can do we haven't got to start that's
right and that doesn't seem to be the
right whatever you do it is something if
we're not happy with what what we we've
already sad another plane where we go we
using here so why we agreed the proposed
changes which jewelry so we don't fly
yes chairman that is seven so we prove
that negative royal all agree the Prime
notes on the annual audit plan B no
mesquite are you saying is a noted
subject to review only because I think
it's imprecision actually to improve it
but I don't think we can change this
plan for 2015-16 I think we can only
with the peer review that will be
looking at next year's I think is that
except for actor yeah that's what I was
going to stay on top of this plan this
is a plan that's already economy
too many of these ordinance to actually
work in progress the rationale for the
reduction was really as a result of the
the resources are available in quarter
one of the year rather than currently
available where we didn't have a
backfill resource in place not bad for
from attorney to cover that back for
resources now on ebay but recognition
that eludes in that time earlier in the
year that we've had to refine some of
the timelines in this we've actually
looked in a lot of detail of the
proposed plan we have some contingency
days which are days that are held in
reserve those days have actually been
utilized now into the plan but it's so a
review of where we are at this point in
time in how many days we think are
required to complete the work at some
place maybe all is there actual proposal
really around systems and processes and
all the critical ones that we feel after
the W is indicated that we can still
complete those within this financial
year part of the pyridine is actually
looking at our systems and processes and
actually what looking at what we've
completed for this year what are the
critical reviews for the what is this
need to be in place for the next
financial does that make sense I'm the
3.6 oh
target sir figures there is there any
any additional information that you
might have to see how that how you might
be going yellow I've got the figures as
at last Friday the actual figure is 61
point ninety seven percent against a
target of 65 so it gave you continue to
to bring that to that gap down do you
think that by the in-depth year ever how
close to the target any sense at moment
if we keep the progression going you
should be always on target by the end of
the segment and then hopefully keep it
going on to that baby Pratt knees
loading Chen still be gay in the moment
my lifetime because that was a different
perspective almost so so how do we want
the recommendation in the progress on
the air new audit plan be agreed and the
revised annual audit plan 2015-16 be
approved i would say noting the further
information that was provided
amazing great can I just make one
comment contingency reserve we had 20
days and we've used for chain we've
still got another six do we need to keep
the other six in reserve you never know
what will crop circle thing about the
the reviews example that person is
proposing times you have to sit with
that so that may take some of them
continue to the diamond was looking that
promoted process but I mean the DB idea
would it came out the blue and that took
32 so you dude you don't Louise on no
wall crumble I would like some comments
to be made on these minutes though
because for instance risk management
controls we allocated 10 days we've only
used three that is seven less you know
there's a three less on payrolls the
seven less on well that's your nation
about the payroll said she came in under
budget that's the plus one so I'll
accept that one I don't like the others
I would like it noted about these days
because I believe we've gone from over
400 last year now down to 302 this year
and I would like it noted and I believe
what probably all in agreement that yes
we've got no choice that this is the
latest um
audit plan we've got to have this audit
plan but I would personally and I think
we're all in agreement market noted
there 302 days down from 400 last year
is not satisfactory and the Audit
Committee r not happy with that both
mommy just sort of stating that in terms
of the it's for me it's not the number
of days it's how those days are used and
those are used in a in in the
appropriate way so for example you view
we could have an audit where at there's
an area that's been given very good
assurance year after year and actually
there may not always be a need to do a
detailed audit at self assessment may be
sufficient it may be better utilizing
those resources and all the areas that
may not actually even live here in on
this schedule yeah so it's really about
it being really clear that the oddest
that we do are effective that were
actually auditing the right own and
we're really clear about where the risk
are again also just in terms of where we
see a variation where a variation occurs
when I thought is being completed that
the big good thing and because it means
that the audience has been completed is
possibly be completed in less time etc
it's more concern say it's an audit
hasn't been completed and there is a
reduction we just need to be clear that
that is still sufficient to do a full
and comprehensive audit of that area and
that's why we still need the
contingencies in reserve because clearly
that might need a there are more days
that are going to be required and of
course the peer review will help us for
next year with allocating the correct
amount of days that we will need to
review the areas that need reviewing all
being clear that there are other any
areas that should be on here that aren't
and any other things that I think that
we should be paying some some specific
attention to and then we can have a look
at what do something for us what we
thought it would be
need to allocate to that because the
third uniform a from an external
position so they may not always fully
understand our own internal processes
etc laron Joan system so we need to sort
of indicate whether there's a rationale
for that not being there what's been
done in the past etc as well and sort of
do that you know absolutely I understand
your explanation but I'm still concerned
and I know 440 days to 302 and I
appreciate where we may be very very
efficient or whatever you completing
these but it's still quite significant
amount of time and reduce for now I hold
it feel that game is a very appropriate
thing to minute it's a minute the fact
and also too many of the explanation
given by Calvin 51 officer because that
makes great sense yeah it also shows in
the minute that we as a committee and as
a group have considered the issues that
were presented to us otherwise it just
looks like a tick box gets it done here
I think too many too many times maybe
this committees has appeared to do that
we're now getting them down there is a
gritty doses and come alive in there
chairman we've gone you were substantial
and I fully accept what the laser said
but we've we've gone from wherever
growth down
302 of no reason you know because of
style coming up but it took us four
hundred and two days when we have more
staff now well I fully accept your
explanation do we have too many style I
mean I mean what why was the needs out
for you know more people taking four
hundred two days and they are suddenly
we can do it on an appropriate 300 and
other days now when we had in the in
previous years I wasn't the only last
year but what you before they in
previous years we have comprehensive
reports and all the rest of the bits and
pieces and even then there was the order
isolating concern about the levels of
audit I mean it was all done and covered
but I don't know Mosby says there is we
do have concerns we keep highlighting
this and regrettably it's dragged on for
too long already and I fully accept an
easy explanation but it actually
highlights the fact that we have more
people until a lot longer and they are
suddenly which will be very efficient
and highlight specific areas well why
didn't we do that two years ago
difficult although we have always done
an end-to-end process on the orders we
do you more or less developed a way of
ensuring that it's total order to be
life on your network you may recall that
when the audit plan was submitted in
June this year I did I suggested that we
were to keep things as they were for
this year with the review is all seen
once the redesigns break it down we have
new external auditors coming in we may
have a different way of approaching
things and that was always the plan this
year was in front of all in Newpointe
was really sort of have a little bit
continuity between the old regime the
new regime and make sure we cover the
key areas
on the back of the new orders coming in
are you expecting inspecting them to
have a slightly different approach or
they're going to do things in a
different way I believe they're a lot
more can be computer-based so that we
taking stuff more out of our systems and
building their samples on that basis I
just might I would anticipate up with
the new external auditors that there
will be a new approach they won't place
as much reliance initially on the work
carried out by our internal or decides
that all want to do their own
walkthrough of the systems I've already
met with Ernst & Young Gun also actually
work with anything young in order to the
county and they do have a very different
approach to a diluted with video I've
had preliminary meeting with lemon I'm
meeting with them again next week to
actually start the review of our own
internal processes of which they'll then
start to think about which areas they
want to start to focus on okay
children we were talking about the
recommendation but actually as I said I
think I'm I suggestive noted subject to
review and I still think from what I
thought that's the purpose because the
review peer review is going to have an
impact upon in early we plan going
forward well I think we did agree that
instead of body plan be agreed be no
teachers and that started to review I I
profit and subject to ring here ya happy
with that 2015-16 such a trivial you
noted subject to a few others always
what we want yeah because they all happy
with that so have something to really in
both places you might I sense if we have
it subject to review does that mean
we've got to have a review date and
we've got to review it again because the
peer review it is is surely looking at
next year's told you I'd be looking at
cisco processes and yes these external
auditors will also be looking at the
internal audit plan and as part of that
and actually deciding which hair I want
to do maybe sixteen seventeen not not
welcome to engage in 1615 60 n so
arresting young when they arrive we're
going to be looking at the audio 4 15 16
and they will look at this audit plan
are they where the lease is sufficient
and which of these areas they actually
want to do a walk-through off for their
processes
and whether there are any areas where
they feel there are missions that will
mean that they will have to down to a
more comprehensive piece of work so it
is something to review so it could end
up more than three hundred and two days
of absolute yes yes to thursday tomato
pie honest and young's available basis
only urban Indians yeah yeah this is MX
o Lord success so I think that's what
we've agreed yeah okay so I don't think
we've got any strangers it's very
strange so we're going also I some oil
chanting oh we haven't any right so this
is Jerry Harper how I believe me really
and I cannot take just a few minutes to
introduce this before we go through a
bigger thing it's quite a large subject
and firstly the apology but it wasn't
given to the sep tember moving the
result of all the constraints of our
restructuring so I'll be required a
fundamental review and just working
physicians who present it sep tember
meeting and what I'd like to do if I can
ease let you initially to the diagram of
a pain to say three this is the name of
the slide
color as well to UK yeah right and
essentially what I've try to display
here is the tiered nature of our whole
risk management arrangements of Rochford
so if I'm sort of taken just threw this
at the very top of the diagram
effectively we have a policy and that
policy is 1 i'm gonna ask you to approve
tonight and you had the policy documents
given to you below that we have a
framework of the arrangements that we
use for managing risk that details the
responsibilities of the various people
involved and also gives you some
guidelines and templates that use for
assessing risk the risk scoring systems
that use and so on and that indeed as
well is something that I'd secure
approval of tonight and then finally in
terms of the doctors you've been
presented there is the corporate risk
register it is a tabular summary of the
key risks nelson spacing of total time
it is divided into what I call outcome
Westside things that could go wrong in
terms of the way we are totally secret
even through our community and if you
want to call in a viewing this which are
if you like the underlying things that
we could get one which would inhibit
what we do how we kind of so that's the
way to instruction and referring to the
diagram though the picture types so
starting with under underpinning all of
this are a number of other pieces of
information and the corporate risk
register each of those risks that's on
there because as a further analysis
available
anyone wants to delve further into any
of those items they're available on
request call the corporate risk analysis
separated the key list we've done an
analysis principal moving across desired
rednecks that and croce the thing called
operational risk refugees this corporate
risk register has given you the key list
the top level rest of the council is
facing if you think about the day-to-day
operations of the council in each of the
assistant directors areas there are of
course day-to-day things that need to be
assessed risk assessed as well so that
area of work is managed by the assistant
directors and they have appointed people
we come operations coordinators their
job is to gauge with me and they produce
their own local risk registers if you
like for day-to-day operational matters
and then finally if you look at our
business plan which you could proved in
the last few months as a council that
will give rise to project delivery pains
that will seek to under table to ensure
that we deliver the various projects
within those project plans there will
also be risk logs and risk analyses for
those specific projects as those plans
are developed so that's the kind of a
little scenario if you like of the risk
management structure that the council
has and then linking all of that
together in a much broader ways with the
whole terms of planning business
continuity work that's done by our midst
of planning officer also has been linked
internet so then athletes of operational
level things that we looked at least
register will also be reflected in
speedy business continuity plans that we
produce for particular area so that when
we talk about having a Chablis on ice to
see we deliver against the risk that
should be featured for example a that we
need lemons you planning for there
as well so that's the kind of whole
scenario if you like this to come back
to what you're being asked to look at
tonight essentially it's the policy
statement the framework to find who does
loss or systems with on whatever's
waiting to score bisque and then the
restrain yourself at the corporate level
those are the three items that were
being asked on the captain island and
approve and I'm happy to go through
those and paper those options so avidly
refer them to acknowledge sure Sammy
don't compose no prob across the site in
question know how that and that's what
we've done the other than good okay
there's something like I just couldn't
turn bottom out like I got down to the
last week pages where we were looking at
specific foreigners and we're looking at
the columns said quality of controlling
right and I noticed that there was as
we're spending on fares so you have like
10 20 nada meeting on you verify those
as a poll which says quality of control
and the fair smattering of payers and
for some groups I couldn't really find
out
probably didn't look as far as I showed
you my gmail is what's the difference
between fair and good and then I'm going
to probably say to you is a white is
only fair right so smoothly aware we're
okay perhaps I can back a step further
from that and say that if you look at
the last four columns on me this
register you've got four items there we
look at the quality of the controls we
have in place I knew things we're trying
to mitigating this with we have a view
on the likelihood of the risk are not be
is it going to be to occur then
obviously how what would the impact that
risk if it does occur and those then
give rise to us taking a view to whether
this degree you hi hello so the risk
rating you alone is the life essentially
from the lightning of an impact on the
quality of controlled impact on the
light of an impact effectively if you've
got poor quality controls then the
lightning of a risk occurring is higher
essentially and so when you've got an
issue with the quality of the controls
you've necessarily got probably a higher
likelihood and they're commonly moving
if you had a better control the impact
less likely to change but sometimes you
can immediately that's as well you can
probably make you bleed we've had less
severe in some cases with a good control
and that in turn then may lower the risk
rating so if we had good controls across
the piece we might find the sum of these
drop back to low in terms of a risk the
position we're in at the moment
essentially an articles comment we've
made already tonight is that we've been
through a major change
kelson we are continuing to go through
and make a change in terms of developing
new ways of doing and necessarily
therefore there are a number of areas
where the control we've had in the past
that probably not in place in as as much
as they use between some councils and so
we are in a situation and I'm trying to
do this is a very fair and honest
assessment where we are we in the past
we've had far more good rated controls
on this list and fewer fair and deep as
a couple of forward of every kind of
organized in the part essentially when
you look at what does that mean if
something is poor what it means it it's
not really helping to control the risk
of a madman either the controls are
there but they're not happening or the
control you put your base are sufficient
if you look affair then you're saying
well there is some mitigation in this
going on it's not adequate when you get
to good where things are plated be okay
and XO of courses you really got maybe
you can handle things in your interviews
in touch with everything so that's kind
of the scenario with we are in specific
risks obviously the specific
explorations come back on our channel
thank you so I mean I'm looking at one
straightaway number 1 i'm thinking i
know put some principal controls already
so they're going to improve that quite
quite quite quite a lot that it's not
loading there and then i'm thinking
about i'm not going to introduce that in
particular it's the river the investment
board and i know what controls have been
put around that in particular to achieve
better better control of the business
plan delivery but having said that i
suppose what i'm interested in these i'm
looking a secular and i'm worrying cuz
that's an affair because that's one of
the biggest risks to this council
in my opinion so that's my plasma view
anyway so I guess what I'm actually
saying is what's the program to improve
these principal controls from there to
at least good and from poor to at least
good we got a program so you ask use for
approval policy the eyeties which is all
fine and dandy but when it in then in
terms of analysis gives me a result that
I don't like what are you going to do to
make it you know to improve it yeah and
again if I come back to the more
detailed analysis this available each of
these so I don't have that which you
don't have programmers good sensitive
lamorak doesn't develop 13 times four
sheets of paper to read it really want
to go through them and essentially these
give areas like further action required
and so here we have for example p
programs that work to be defined plans
identify key priorities for service
delivery those are the things that are
currently being developed with the
within the leadership team at the moment
is something these is really sort of
germane to what they're doing right now
and if you look at safeguarding and the
sort of things that the lead officer
there said is that he wants to do more
training among staff because there has
been training there is a feeling that we
now need to refresh their training
because most of us aren't going to get
involved in safeguarding issues most of
the time so there is a need to just keep
your own people's agendas to make sure
that we are all aware of the things we
should be doing you know a process chart
was issued probably about three months
ago and I suspect that everybody's
looked leonel far bit because it's not
something that evening on a daily basis
so we need to keep these things in the
forefront of people's minds so there
will be some port
refresher training approach being
organized to that we need to undertake
certain audits now I don't know when the
last one was done at a magnificent
losses because section 11 Children's Act
audit required and that has to be done
on a regular basis so we need to make
sure those things are happening so in
each of these risks there is a kind of
underpinning analysis it says and this
is the action we are the need to take or
are taking and those are things that we
bring back to the leadership team for
them to move up to i'm sorry to convert
it naturally falls to me to say i think
we should all have seen that because I
think that's far what we should be doing
I know I don't feel terribly comfortable
acknowledging this current risen results
outcome or analysis outcome without
knowing what we're doing to to improve
it which I'm i know this evidence number
of these areas will be as a result of
public service transformation so we
expect to see something like the
business plan that is something very new
its transformation of a service and
you'd actually need to watch the pros
process safeguarding will always match
english register and effective to see
you there what we should what we can do
bridgeview the action go into the detail
actions based on which of these you
believe you want to see this is the
third oh this is the latest regional
report I think for yourselves to say
which of these you are particularly
concerned about what to have more of a
drill down into and we can bring those a
share those details with you but
recognize that some of them what we want
to seize the trajectory and the process
and those principles being invaded so
where we mentioned the approach in
safeguarding need for training actually
it needs to be what we live in burien
every day these two what we do and those
principles Newton's yet just be
continually refreshed and actually or
was not to incite of that so again there
are some actions are in place once you
start to do that but that aerials the
one that you will always see on this
register and what we want to see is that
progress from fair to go to in terms of
the quality control that we have in
place and what we can share with you the
action plans without any of the other
areas that you feel would be of interest
yourself for a further drill down but
rather than bringing to you this
thinking is responsibility to advise
which of those you want to be more an
in-depth review of Germany if I'm a time
just to leave a warm sand castles as
concerns around safeguarding the DBS
checks and processes that has
been done on homes i had to go through
the process myself when I was appointed
the children's exported that has been
done I know because I Centauri matter
yeah yeah no I know that because that
has been done I don't know the results
are but I know that because you're the
outgoing assistant director at time had
sent out chase assoc institution that
was done and not forgetting that you now
have an appointed safeguarding officer
in post which improves they didn't have
so there are there are those issues are
being addressed so just to alleviate
some of your concerns
and also with the outgoing assistant
director of what was it was under
community service previously but now we
have we have left it that was passed on
to mr. Halton Marcus hatem to look after
in the interim until we get the new
appointment of it so we haven't just as
assistant directors we haven't ignored
the safe garden side see if we can yeah
just two sisters no no no no I suggested
but I'm just saying just to alleviate
any concerns around safeguarding for
members that is top of our priority list
it's jordan saw something that was
certainly not no notion of my budget
request me my my travel is towards our
accountability care responsibility as
members with on this committee because
we are the ones who have been appointed
by counsel you know to do this and I
just felt that I'd want to go much
further next to have that assurance so i
can honestly walk away from an audit
committee and say yeah i've looked at
this and I'm reasonably sure I might
even want to add to it but i'm not sure
and and also the other members would
contribute to it that we do have you
know that plan that actual plan approved
in a water or will we are we know where
we where we got to go there are quite a
few things i'm clean it so much so you
can make them thank you as well thank
you Joe sorry to tell ya
sorry I'm sorry yeah a young mother once
it's a sort of icing just stand out to
me was the regard to use food and help
in fact they mentioned that one of the
potential risks assess or fatality or
sore laughs ran into or five amenities
and yes obviously there should be a
major concern the fact this poor is
obviously a bigger concern is if one
that's always going to be an area that's
going to be difficult to score I know or
is there there the fact that we haven't
got sufficient controls in the area the
moment the current situation is that we
have there's a shortage we have one gun
safety inspector in post at the moment
we have just taken on a second
contractor I believe in order to deal
with any backlog of food safety
inspections that is good enough that is
why this is risky to sport moment was
reflecting the nature of the situation
right now the plan is to have other
thing the contractor has started now so
I've seen their name compulsory every
day so they are attacking the backlog
really affect from nail they will need
to work flat out the rest of this year
to achieve the inspection and those from
a previous work experience
word for my family business about and we
used to sell cleaning products and we
knew when the inspectors were going
around because suddenly the wing people
start coming through them what they need
to do to get their premises up to
scratch so from experience I know that a
good inspection regime is helps to keep
the level of safety at the area only
support a high standard and you can get
it wrong in there are there can be
serious consequences luckily so far we
haven't had any serious consequences but
it's something that we do need the
function show yes not the facility shoot
think the start of the year there were
warm premises of the district of the
voting 05 this company 11 which is still
only a small percentage return number
premises provide 11 is equal to the
total number of the south bank crossing
point and batter the put together so
slightingly assure that contrasted to do
the back door I would assume the reason
for the number on myspace part because
premises up in be inspected some sort of
the zeolites we developed quite well
chandus Elijah as you know I'm give the
outgoing assistant director held that
we've had difficulties with that first
under but however we did have two free
safety officers but it must be noted
that one of the food safety of hers that
had left prior to the restructure and I
believe we did hadn't have another
contractor in after that to help draw
down the numbers and then through
various factors that our only remaining
food and safety inspector broke his foot
they can come out on site so there was
various factors but they all being
addressed at the moment as you know yeah
we have got now got a new contractor and
that should quite quickly draw down the
back
our others food safety inspectors back
on to full health standards or hope
subjects in touch or date nothing else
but but given the fact that we've had
this difficult bedding in period and
lack resources i think we've been quite
we've been done quite well with regards
to our as well as well as we can do on
our food safety inspections in touch
with there hasn't been any serious cases
out doing in touch with touch with it's
not in any sink serious and yeah well I
I'm hope I'm paper all back on track now
with regards to food safety and of
course you know we are in the middle of
recruiting a new assistant director
narrow you should bring a whole new
perspective to as well well it was
Leslie's saying earlier actually and we
do rely on our wrestling bars in the
Rockford area so it is an essential
partner we keep make sure that food
safety is at the top of the linea I'm
not quite sure if you will be aware
yellow paper barthel job of many touched
on in about the investment old are they
and how do you feel you'll be involved
or with this situation I mean well I
mean I had a meeting last evening I want
me i'm not a bald but listening to it
and it's going to be very much a
supplicant see scenario at times how do
you feel no but i would go back to
probably Nick Carle who's the lead
director with responsibility the
business plan and if actually say how do
you feel these new controls are going to
represent
and then I pick up on the fact that you
know we can add that in as a control in
action that we can evaluate you but Joey
now help you biggest one of them one of
them two proposals which we discussed
last night was to ensure that there is a
project office project office is a
professional office that takes
responsibility for independently not
auditing for independently reviewing and
ensuring that all projects are two-time
have the resources and to a certain
extent our meeting budget controls and
that will be two to two offices it might
even end up three officers with the size
of the program and we go in line so you
know you can add that to the principal
controls and if you if you read the
paper I supplied to mr and the directors
from from the cram well then you you'd
be reasonably assured that we've looked
at the very best of practice in putting
that in place and although will not end
to you know use every Bell and whistle
in the project office on day one I think
it will inevitably my breasts so that
that helps absolutely swearing as well
yeah since a is just a question how is
it has it all going to jail together
well that's a good control respect you
as well as of course fairly obviously
the alessan board itself who will save
your calls from the on the project
office and of course at our offices and
principal officers who are running the
projects anyway as long as it definitely
won't contradict or won't be in any way
a variation or more moderate counselors
policies or what we are well that itself
is why I raised the issue of ethics and
culture sorry champ I raised ethics and
culture and how that was going to be
because clearly we set a new culture
glass line for that particular part of
the council's work and yes that does
need to be looked at and assurance given
around and I'm looking forward to that
happening that is it work for me just
sort of adding to dance or nothing else
exactly the point I was going to make in
terms of generally with an investment
Ward you expect to see a PMO which is a
project management office to support the
functions and do some of the Quality
Assurance but you'd also anticipate that
each of the propositions come with a
fully costed business proposition but
it's also how to proprietary diligence
done prior to actually come into the
investment board on within that should
actually also be a risk section which
outlines the risk into which what would
being potentially exposed once the
propositions are approved or endorse
expect to see proper project management
principles with risk management
schedules to support each of these as
they go forward to out there they should
then something amazing probably see that
working fully in practice and to add to
that filmmaking equals more to discuss
that's impressive I'm happy with that I
have I suspect that you mentioned two
officers you know third on they were 13
bold in their congratulations ok no
questions on item 10 members
recommendation my turn to do something
about
it is proposed that 20 resolves the
updated corporate risk management policy
and framework and the corporate risk
register 2015-16 be approved I don't
what I say because yeah but I have my
memory wasn't complete but I don't want
to retrieve that corporate this register
because I think it requires us to look
over the actions that are being taken to
be obviously you discuss something else
coming into place yeah okay well that's
that's by the by i'm also talking about
the other ones ala members raised which
is you know obviously vulnerable
children vulnerable people and food and
all the others I don't think from my own
responsibility and accountability ones
are dissected say to look a particular
one I'd like to see that wonderful paper
that's sitting there before i prove the
corporate risk register happy to improve
the policy need to approve it Jen sorry
we need is it necessary requirement so
you don't have to pretty personal look
at what we're going to recommend tell my
thing is known if I'd be happy to
approve the policy in the framework are
not prepared to approve the outcome
because I'm not satisfied with the
outcome so then be approved then to be
noted against I want to go further
I think the biz my name is pathology my
favorite to be improved yeah sorry so
again I'm sensing that it's perfect
committee to approve for call the risk
management policy framework but the cool
yes right yeah yes home town until such
time as the action plan is called
forward right so then the update is
called excuse me corporate risk
management policy and framework be
approved and the corporate risk register
for 2015-16 be no change subject to the
action plan bring being brought forward
where we just managed to history yeah
that's okay too don't know what to put
it in our requirement that the actual
plan is given to the next meeting we're
ready noting it so we're not giving a
mother green light panel to the next one
sorry I'm thinking let me try that it's
too long was there something at the last
night's meeting at the recent register
was under review or under change or
evolve in any way so sorry Denise
children the corporate risk register
will be evolving it will change every
time you see it it can involve in live
document or they will actually always be
to note but it's for the committee to
identify any areas where they wish to
more in-depth review of the actual
details of the action plans okay so here
we have read this one yet yeah read the
policy innovation prove that yeah noting
the corporate returns double 2015-16
yeah wish to see the action plans for
those that are recorded under quality of
controls fair and poor
so we have a big tits they're not
written this way isn't good luck right
now now we'll go on to I jump before and
that's an exclusion of the present
perfect but we haven't got any
volleyball in Sweden Sweden so